oh
irène chagnaud propose voyage sans
passeport
vous voyez cette langue de terre qui
pointe et bien c'est la côte occidentale
de sicile avec dans le fond les îles et
gagnent
autrefois les pirates surveillait les
navires marchands qui allait y revenait
de tunisie du levant de constantinople
mais aujourd'hui ce qui nous intéresse
ce sont les lagunes ses défauts blanc
qui s'étendent au loin sur plus de 1000
hectares et ce petit moulin à vent qui
semble un jouet au bord de la mer
vous l'avez deviné il s'agit de salim
c'est très simple au bord de la mer les
moulins complot pour la distribuer dans
les bassins sont des moulin à six ailes
qui rappellent ceux des îles de la mer
egée ses salines qui s'étendent jusqu'à
marsala existe le fils étant très
reculées
pline l'ancien on parle déjà dans son
histoire naturelle
la concentration dans les bassins
devient de plus en plus forte au fur et
à mesure que l'eau s'évapore sous la
chaleur implacable du soleil et au mois
d'août il ne reste plus qu'une croûte de
sel
les ouvriers se protège le mieux
possible contre la réverbération qui est
terrible et aussi contre l'action
corrosive du sel qui est non moins
terrible en tournant vous avez vu
ramasser le sel en pyramide une seule
salines possède ce ruban mécanique
les ouvriers viennent déverser le
contenu de leurs sauts le sel est
acheminé un cyber attaque unique placée
au bord du canal
les ouvriers font équipe part de la
remplissant le saut et l'autre faisant
leva et regarder la beauté du mouvement
quand ils prennent le saut pour charger
sur l'épaule
dans les autres salles in le travail se
fait comme du temps depuis chaque homme
portant sur l'épaule sa charge jusqu aux
états unis la production totale annuelle
est d'environ 180 mille tonnes presque
tout est destinée à l'exportation et aux
industries chimiques du nord de l'ipl
les marchés les plus importants sont la
norvège la suède la finlande et 10 ans
on exporte aussi en hollande au canada
et au japon
ce sel friable et particulièrement
apprécié dans la salle izzo du poisson
et maintenant nous voici le vent karpine
haut perché sur son piton comme d'autres
vieux village des poules
ceci est la grand place la place du
peuple avec son église et anne obélisque
ajouté là pour les besoins de la
perspective ce petit palais rose un peu
prétentieux tout temps les guirlandes
c'est la demeure de don césar où habite
mariette l'héroïne du film la loi
bonjour toi lan et nous sommes
maintenant devant un engin bizarre cet
engin est un engin de pêche
il fait partie intégrante de cet
amoncellement de poutres de cordes de
filet de planches de caves de trail
accroché au bord des rochers qui
surplombe la négative de loin on dirait
une immense araignée malcor grand bateau
qui va doubler la pointe
ce très beau qu'aussi puisque fera
beaucoup il s'agit est un des plus
importants de l'accord même le plus
important vraiment il est immense il a
sept grands mâts un filet à cette côte
est et 12 hommes d'équipage plus le ch a
bien entendu parce qu'il ya paraît-il
là-bas toujours un chat bien sûr pas des
poissons
des pêcheurs en construit là il ya
peut-être deux ou trois mille ans les
textes grecs on trouve plusieurs
descriptions de ces machines à pêcher
keyboard adriatique
cela correspond tout à fait à ce que
nous voyons ici on ne sait pas quelle
est l'origine exacte de ces travaux qu
mais elles doivent être très ancienne
elle date tout simplement du moment où
on a inventé le filet la poulie et le
cabestan
après chaque tempête les pêcheurs ont un
travail terrible ils doivent tout
remettre en état remplacer un morceau
when our quelquefois changé à ma ils
doivent ajouter les cordages et les
câbles des tordus retendre les pizzas
enfin vraiment travailler énormément
c'est un travail qui demande plusieurs
jours tels que fois plus qu'une semaine
en voici un autre trabucco la modèle
plus familial il est beaucoup plus
simple et un seul homme le fait
fonctionner la manoeuvre du filet et
commandé par des câbles qui
conditionnait poulies et qui sont
enroulés sur et cabestan l'homme pour
nan piétinant parfois les chevaux aux
aveugles qui faisait tourner les moulins
le filet s'élève lentement et le câble
son rôle
voilà le fil est ressort tout doucement
le fonds sera bientôt à fleur d'eau et
nous verrons la pêche l'homme va bloquer
le travail dès que le fonds va
apparaître il ne restera plus qu'à
ramasser poisson voyez c'est extrêmement
simple
au fond il suffisait d'y penser on peut
évidemment pas dire qu'il y ait beaucoup
de poissons et qu'il soit très très
content
enfin comment recommence la de la
manoeuvre toutes les demi heures
on finit tout de même par ramasser
quelque chose
sur quelque chose étant le plus souvent
une excellente petite friture ce bateau
va maintenant traverser en 2h ou
peut-être en 3 le boulot mer adriatique
qui nous sépare des îles primitive il
merveilleusement sauvage
il il habitait en face lille saint
nicolas
en tout il y à trois kilomètres carrés
et 300 habitants c'est le reste d'un
immense archipel qui sépare des jusqu'à
la grèce et qui s'est effondré dans les
temps préhistoriques
catz à belvédère
la population ce groupe pour voir
débarquer deux fois par semaine les
touristes
c'est d'ailleurs la seule occupation
quelque peu d'avoir cette population
en or de s'occuper d'elle même il n'y a
pas d'hôtel
si l'on peut visiter il faut emporter sa
tante de moins si on veut y rester
ouvrir seulement bien entendu pour la
journée le ballon qui amène les
touristes mélange entre les il débarque
attaché à la queue leu leu promène les
touristes autour
le village comprend deux rues le corso
diomay du nom du héros grec antique
l'ami du lips qui l'avait accompagné à
la guerre de troie et qui va mourir
paraît-il dans cet hymne
parlementaire est passée par là il y a
cinq ans et il y a été particulièrement
fêté la teste cette inscription le corso
conduit au château et à l'abbaye
d'ailleurs il serait bien difficile de
super on en ligne qui a à peu près de
kilomètres de long et 800 mètres de
large
alain derrière des fortifications se
trouve la petite église santa maria
il ya beaucoup souper à les intempéries
surtout des batailles que les religieux
ont livré à plusieurs reprises pour les
pirates
elle est encore très innovante avec sa
façade sculptée
les bénédictins suffit à construire un
cloître après les verdicts avaient
restée siens ces religieux remportèrent
au xvième siècle du poireau tente
hissant sur 150 ghallef tueur de 1938
1943 lille a servi de résidence ou
déportés politiques du fascisme
nous allons à présent et arguin quitter
san nicola dans les murailles l'église
et le château se confondent sur la roche
brûlé par le soleil
et nous allons prendre cette partie qui
va nous emmener après une longue
traversée en vue des idées au lierre
si vous êtes sportif et vous ayez
beaucoup de loisirs
vous pouvez faire le trajet dans un
vieux voiliers comme celui ci un vieux
navire de charge qui revient à vide ils
sont enchantés de vous prendre à bord
il y à sept îles éoliennes elle
s'appelle vous le savez bien sûr je me
permets de vous le rappeler néanmoins
lipari and area vulcano salina alice ou
dit phyllis ou 10 et stambouli
et si vous aimez la vitesse si vous êtes
de votre siècle vous prendrez cet engin
rapide il vous emportera plus vite aux
fruits de son moteur mais vous y perdrez
la consoeur de billes
on
irène chagnaud vous a proposé voyage
sans passeport cette émission a été
réalisée avec un film de maxime clairet
sont michel durand montage christian de
murger fric jacqueline noir et d'une
station sonore de minutes paul abine
réalisation solange péters